Democrats in panic mode after a terrible
debate performance could cost them
control of the Senate Democrat John
Federman and Republican Dr mametaz
clashing in their one and only debate
before Pennsylvania voters cast their
ballots and it was a total train wreck
for the left fetterman who's recovering
from a stroke not only stumbling through
his answers but flip-flopping on key
issues watch
hi good night everybody and let's also
talk about the elephant in the room I
had a stroke he's never let me forget
that and my Dr L believes that I'm fit
to be serving and that's what I believe
is where I'm standing John Federman
doing this crime wave has been trying to
get as many murderers convicted and
sentenced to life in prison out of jail
as possible I believe that I run on my
record on crimes I'm the only person on
this stage right now that has con is
successful about pushing back against
gun violence there is that 2018
interview that you said quote I don't
support fracking at all so how do you
square the two I I do support fracking
and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking
betterments Camp blaming the captioning
system provided for him is being delayed
and filled with errors but that quickly
got shut down team fetterman also
dropping f-bombs to spin the awful
performance as a win
I think the people of Pennsylvania saw a
relatable guy who's been doing his
recovery in public for quite some time
and for a guy who was just in the you
know the hospital months ago took it to
Dr Oz pretty far tonight
and Democrats in the liberal media
having a hard time convincing themselves
that the party just didn't totally blow
it
was hard to watch frankly it's very
obvious that he is imperative and maybe
the next cycle would have been the
better cycle for him to run because we
require representation I think it takes
real bravery to allow people to see your
weakness right there was such intense
scrutiny often ableist scrutiny
Republicans are out there tonight saying
that fetterman is unfit he should
withdraw but do they not have a race in
the state of Georgia someone running for
the very same position in Herschel
Walker who's facing family scandals lies
about his past jobs
Greg that was hard to watch did you feel
bad for John fetterman up there no I
felt bad for Oz did you yeah he was
terrible no uh I know actually I I think
Oz did a good I mean it was like it was
like having bad Wi-Fi you know Fatima
just kept going in and going out I felt
kind of bad for him but he could have
diffused the bomb much better if he just
said you know when he said elephant he
should have said look my mind works fine
but my body's catching up I feel like
I'm a dial-up modem right now in a 5G
World make a joke but there wasn't a
joke to diffuse the situation and I this
abeless scrutiny BS look pretending to
be concerned or disgusted because people
are talking about that you put him out
there you put him out there you're
allowing everybody to watch this so it's
on you if you say people are being able
we don't mind Dan Crenshaw right we
don't mind Governor Abbott so we're not
ableist we're talking about is this guy
fit for the job and there's a reason why
you're mad because you didn't want him
to debate because it looks so bad and
now you have him out there now you're
trying to pin it on everybody else but I
did I felt like I was watching Leia
Thomas swimming with you know the girls
swim team it just wasn't fair but I
think that Oz did pretty good he I felt
like he was letting up on the gas when
it got bad you did yeah I thought you
thought that was smart yeah okay yeah
Dana we're actually we haven't shown you
basically everything I mean you could
look at every single answer and be like
oh my God that was horrible what happens
now sort of so we were on a little text
thread last night and whatever stream I
was watching was about I think two
minutes behind where you guys were and
so I was like and I so I was
anticipating like oh wow that was bad I
could see what was coming so I think a
couple of things one I think it's
notable that Dr Oz did not say anything
about the stroke he agreed to the closed
captioning he allowed that to happen the
second thing is they started early
voting in September September 19th I
believe for this election over way over
a million votes have already been cast
and there was a news nation that the
host of the debate they had a focus
group and there were some Democrats
there who and leaning in Independence
that were leaning Democrat who were
already thinking oh boy wait what have
we done and that doesn't necessarily
mean that they would have voted for Dr
Oz maybe they would have but they might
have chosen Conor lamb who was the other
Democrat who was running in the primary
John federman's stroke was before the
primary then he and his wife kept
telling everybody he's fine he's fine
he's fine remember like for about eight
weeks and now they're saying um there
are some Democrats saying oh maybe he
never should have debated anyway I think
that's wrong like if you aren't really
concerned about democracy and you want
Integrity in elections I think debates
are important and as you move forward in
the states and thinking about these
rules perhaps early voting should not be
allowed to start until after the first
debate has been held I think that would
be fair the next thing is I think this
team uh his team needs to get their
story straight the first thing they came
out and said John fetterman did a great
job strong performance and that guy uses
the f word right to say how great it was
then the next thing they do is they try
to say that the technology was to blame
for the stumbles and that forced the
company next star to come out and say
actually it worked perfectly fine this
is what they agreed to and all of that
if Republicans win in Pennsylvania
they're going to get the majority so I
think that's why you have a lot of
Democrats sort of hand-wringing this
morning but aside from the stroke I do
want to say I think that it was a bad
policy debate for fetterman on energy
horrible on the economy and on crime in
particular student debt all of those it
on the issues it wasn't strong either
really really bad and he was asked by
the moderator twice and I think the
moderators did a pretty good job are you
going to release your medical records
and he still after this will not release
the records he refuses to release the
records the look the guy had a stroke I
think it's five months ago okay many
people who have strokes are right now in
rehab been therapy and cognitive therapy
it is clear that he did not have the
ability to answer anything beyond the
most the most you know
how can I say this that's superficial
right part of it there was no in-depth
no substantive discussion he could not
go down to A B C or D and so he promotes
himself saying see I showed how good I
am how great I'm feeling I don't know
that anyone who watched that debate is
saying to themselves gee that's the guy
I want to represent me in the Senate
this guy couldn't answer why he's
against it was against fracking four
years ago but now is in favor of it and
you could say it's a stroke and you know
God bless him I hope he gets better but
we're talking about the Senate we're
talking about a country that's divided a
country where everything matters every
fact every issue you just don't look at
the substance the The Superficial layer
you've got to go down he's got a
progressive socialist ideology where he
wants to release one-third of the
criminals in prison he wants to get rid
of parole for lifers who were in jail I
mean this is a guy who is not uh in the
mainstream and there's no question
September 19th they started voting and
now he has the debate on October 25th
whether it's 650 000 or a million have
already voted they can't change that
vote and there's one more thing I want
to say you know it just reminded me of
Joe Biden remember Joe Biden he was in
the basement we've got kovid and his
wife Jill is walking him around I feel
like the same thing is happening here
with fetterman's wife saying oh he's
fine he's fine maybe maybe you should be
taking better care of him maybe he
should be in rehab maybe this isn't the
time for him to be running you know it's
just my opinion and and of all
candidates it's fetterman that Barack
Obama and Joe Biden are going to go to
Pennsylvania together and campaign with
together what does that tell you well I
think you I think you framed right this
this race here could very well determine
decide who is in the majority in the
Senate it was painful to watch there's
no doubt this is a a person a human
being who clearly uh is battling his
recovery and battling with the recovery
to get through and you have to hope and
prayed he does get through it but I'm
not sure it affects the outcome uh in
any in any meaningful way I think that
the issues here that Dana raised or
issues that he's been campaigning on
from the very beginning and he won the
Primary he's now it sounds seems like
he's three or four points ahead here in
the uh and as we get to the November
here I do think an argument should be
made about can be made about this early
vote piece but voters who don't want to
go vote early don't have to go vote
early and if if Oz had been had had a
poor performance some may have said well
maybe maybe I should have held my vote
back to see how how he made it performed
or high in the affair during the debate
look Obama Biden everyone's going to
descend upon this state and frankly for
Democrats what they're really hoping is
that Shapiro the gubernatorial candidate
the Democratic good material candidate
who I think is the best best Democratic
good material candidate in the country
can help pull fetterman over the over
the Finish Line as well you want
fetterman in the Senate well I I don't
what I do want or the some of his views
and some of his ideas I don't agree with
all of it crazy ideas
I was more of someone else in that race
I was supportive of in the primary his
politics that politics of counter lamb
was more like mine yeah that being said
I'm not sure this affected the outcome
this is not going to influence the
outcome of this race very much I'll take
this debate he's a wounded animal that
can't cut it in Washington and that's a
sad part of it yeah that is a set I'm
not saying I'd agree with them that is
the reality of it hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else